The Joe Rogan experience. Yeah.
And with less alcohol. Well,
the other thing is that these companies,
they don't understand the culture.
It's a different culture.
You can't bullshit us.
Like you can't bullshit us
with marketing and advertising.
That shit is not going to work.
You can't have like the most interesting
man in the world selling the weed state,
state thirsty my friends
now that ain't gonna work.
You gotta get somebody
like Michael Phelps. Yeah,
man fell for real.
I would buy weed from Michael Phelps.
How funny was it that he got in
trouble for that? You know what?
I find it funny is how,
how, um, you know, they,
they put these stereotypes on stoners
for so long like that we're lazy,
unproductive and all that stuff.
This guy's one of the most
decorated Olympians in the history.
You know what I mean? What
does he got like 15 gold
fucking settles. Preposterous.
Yeah. Mister big lungs. That's what
we call him mister big lungs. Fuck.
I probably could take a rip on a
bond. Think about it and my God, Shit,
right. He had probably is
crazy capacity there. It is.
Probably snap a two gram boldest goal
is the person who ratted him out.
Some Logan, some kids, some terp dickhead.
What a piece of shit. Yeah.
Imagine is going on party,
trying to have a good time.
Some kids there with his phone.
That's social network for you though.
They want to go viral so they'll,
they'll get you in that moment where
you know you're supposed to be a friend.
But that was like before all
out of that shit was happening.
Like what year was that? Let's
guess. What gear was that?
12 2012 well before, yeah, before a,
let's just say before, you
know, uh, Instagram kicked off,
but there was still youtube and Twitter,
you know,
if you wanted to put somebody on blast
or you wanted to have a viral video,
youtube has been there for a long time.
Yeah. Twitter was like 2007 right?
Wasn't it? I believe so, yeah. I
think when was Michael, why don't,
was it Michael Phelps? When did he
get in trouble? I'm looking at, I,
I'm seeing different stuff. So I saw
a picture of it on youtube from 2009,
so that means it would have
been in 2008 Olympics, but, oh,
let's see if that makes sense.
Like it was a long time ago. Yeah,
that makes sense though, because he
didn't, he came back, right? Yeah.
He retired and then he came back.
Well, I think he was suspended.
I think it was suspended in 2009 is
when he got caught. And then, uh,
and then he had to,
you know,
do the suspension and he came back and
got some more metals like, Haha, fuck you.
Right. I love that it was, he
suspended because of the weed. Yeah.
Well, you know, hey, listen on, on, uh,
in a lot of places it's still on a
banned substance list. Oh yeah. Texas.
Texas is a real bad.
February, 2008, well, 2009,
he was only 23 apologize incident
where he was caught on camera.
The parties smoking a bong that
was allegedly marijuana. So,
you know,
he shouldn't have apologized for that.
Shouldn't have had to have
apologized for that thing,
is that they have those guys bent over
a box because they're all just trying to
get that sponsorship money. Right. Because
yeah, you have to be squeaky clean.
If you want to be on the Wheaties
box, you can't be an Olympian. Yeah.
They're not going to put Cypress hill
on the Wheaties boxes. Yes. Yeah.
Wouldn't that be great
though, but take the t, h, l,
e and could it d a n,
I. E. S F plus Wheaties.